Ciao ragazzi bentornati alla seconda
parte della "Posta di Sonia"
Io direi a questo punto...scusami, volevi dire qualcosa? Nono niente, vai vai
Sono partito. E' partito come un treno in corsa. Ti seguo ti seguo. Con questa forza che ci
contraddistingue. Vediamo un pochino
quali sono i consigli che...oggi ci
chiedono. Esatto ci vogliono chiedere. Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, la mia situazione è un po' complicata
Io sono una professoressa e ho una cotta immane per un mio alunno, ovviamente minorenne
e quindi situazione complicatissima, io non riesco a togliermelo dalla testa
Ho anche paura che mi arrestino sinceramente oltre a quello che puo' succedere in una situazione del genere
Io non voglio che questa persona meravigliosa esca dalla mia vita, non so come fare
E' un argomento molto attuale. Amo la tua diplomazia. Continua, è tuo! I giornali, i telegiornali hanno parlato di
una situazione analoga ma che è arrivata
magari a degli estremi...a follia...si quella è follia
perché una persona insomma matura, grande, sa. E' vero che oggi i quindicenni
i quattordicenni sembra che ne dimostrano trenta
scusate ma questo capita anche per le
ragazze però insomma ti rapporti sempre
con un minore, con tutte le conseguenze
poi che insomma ne seguono, quindi essere
una buona insegnante, essere una buona
amica ci sta però credo che poi uno deve
anche fare un bel passo indietro e
insomma direzionare i propri interessi
emotivi su altre cose insomma. Non credo
che sia...una situazione sicuramente
difficile per lei. Assolutamente...nessuno vuole...bravissima! Cioè per carità a volte ci
lasciamo trascinare da certi sentimenti,
emozioni che è difficile no...mettere un
bel freno però qui bisogna anche far
funzionare un po' il cervello e dire
"Cambio strada". Anche perché come hai detto tu
qua si sta parlando veramente
di un qualcosa che potrebbe essere
grave qualora si dovessero superare
determinati limiti, a livello legale
professionale. Ti faccio proprio un
discorso da amico che è "Non fare c*****e!", semplicissimo
Ciao Gu...mi sono tolta un dente del giudizio
infatti non so se riesci a
capire quello che sto dicendo. Mi si è
gonfiato tutto, voglio sbattere la testa
al muro. Niente ho bisogno di un po' di
conforto. Che cosa posso fare? Ti sei mai tolto
un dente del giudizio? Io sto impazzendo dal dolore, gonfiore e insomma, altro. C'ha tutto. E' disperata
Comunque grazie per avermi ascoltato, ciao
Condividiamo, ti siamo vicini e solidali
perché ne ho tolti 2. Io zero quindi...Vedi, sei giudizioso e bravo, Sai quelle cose che servono per congelare
nel surgelatore, che metti nella borsa frigo quando vai in giro eh?
Che li piazzi...Magari non proprio a diretto
contatto con la faccia perché dopo oltre
al gonfiore c'è pure l'ustione, quindi no.
Però magari avvolto in un panno già
comunque il ghiaccio attutisce un
pochino il dolore. Scusa non aiuta anche
quelle cose tipo i polaretti, i ghiaccioli. Si cose fresche da tenere...ti anestetizzi la bocca a furia di ghiaccio
...da ingoiare, che neanche la lingua poi
capito? Quella va per conto suo e se è tutto
gonfio e addormentato è una situazione.
Dovrebbe tipo prendersi un lecca lecca
con una tazza sotto, così che ci sbava dentro
una roba inguardabile. E se serve alla cosa
va benissimo
Guarisci presto così si dice. Sei una
professionista, io già andavo
avanti senza un augurio, senza un "In bocca al lupo"
Io sono una ragazza molto ambiziosa che si
butta giù per praticamente tutto, senza
nessun motivo. Sono stata bocciata un paio di volte e devo
ancora finire la scuola, quando avrei
dovuto già finirla. Non lo so io ho
sempre paura di non essere mai
abbastanza e di non arrivare a fare i miei
sogni. Quindi non lo so un consiglio potrebbe magari
essermi utile. Che carina. Io questa la
chiamo paura di vincere
Quando tu fai di tutto per autosabotarti, automaticamente tu non hai
paura di perdere perché già stai
perdendo, cioè stai facendo di tutto per
...quindi la paura è quella di provare e non
riuscirci. Credo che questa pigrizia sia
veramente il tuo problema perché il tuo
buttarti giù molto probabilmente è
legato al fatto che ti aspetti che le
cose siano più semplici, siano più facili
non debbano essere per forza frutto di
un pochino di sudore. il mio invito è
quello di buttarti un pochino più nella
mischia e non aver paura di fallire
perché falliscono tutti quanti, ma chi
fallisce male, per male intendo in una
maniera sbagliata e chi non prova
proprio. E dire "Oh cavolo ce l'ho fatta
stavolta". Ci possono essere anche queste, come si dice...queste battaglie perse perché non tutti
insomma abbiamo gli stessi tempi, lo
stesso modo di crescere e di affrontare
le cose. Questi stop che uno ha servono
anche per diventare un po più forti
Il problema è che nella vita così come ogni
giorno ti devi ricordare di respirare per
campare, perché altrimenti se respiri una volta
ogni tanto non ti andrà comunque bene e
la stessa cosa specialmente se sei
ambiziosa. Dai fuoco a questa cosa e a
continuare anche con la scuola insomma.
Benissimo! In bocca al lupo. Oh lo sai che lo
stavo per dire perché ho detto "Mo ho imparato, ho
imparato che devo dire "in bocca al lupo". E tutti dicono
"Viva il lupo". Io dico sempre grazie, e tutti mi
dicono "Sbagli, devi dire viva il lupo"
Crepi!. io ho sempre detto grazie, pensa te.
Ero speciale! Guglielmo, ti amo!
Ma no! Ragazzi, qua è capito, la posta del cuore
Tutto rosso è diventato. Vabbé ti ringrazio. In bocca al lupo! In bocca al lu.. non c'entra, vabbè in bocca al lupo
Sono una ragazza musulmana, penso che non sia solo mio problema
ma ce l'hanno parecchie ragazze musulmane
che sono nate in Italia o all'estero. il fatto è che
sono affezionata ad una persona che non
è dalla mia stessa religione.
Ovviamente i miei genitori vorrebbero
vedermi con una persona della mia stessa religione. Non so come la penderebbero se
dovessero sapere che io ho deciso o
deciderò di stare con una persona a
prescindere dalla loro religione o
magari anche dal loro sesso. Non la
prenderebbero molto bene. Un saluto a te e e chi avrai accaduto nella prossima puntata...un bacio
Ricambiato. Un bacio. In realtà se ci pensi tutti
quanti i figli di persone praticanti in
maniera importante sono molto più simili
di quanto non si pensi, anche se uno
crede in Allah, uno crede in Dio, uno crede in quello. In
realtà sono molto più simili tra di loro
di quanto non si creda perché? Perché
vivono questo pressing di quelli che
sono i dogmi che gli vengono imposti.
C'è un momento in cui ami la mamma, il
papà e c'è un momento in cui il loro
amore è un amore che ti nutre, ti fa bene
C'è un momento in cui ami te stesso o te
stessa in questo caso e quell'amore che
ti nutre e che ti fa bene devi un pochino
dartelo tu, essere un po forte. Perché
poi le dice anche che non sa come i
genitori possano reagire
Può darsi pure che invece una situazione
del genere, conoscendo questa persona
possano anche cambiare idea, anche perché
insomma, voglio dire, mica per forza deve
essere, ci deve essere un atteggiamento
sempre così di divieto. E inoltre io
magari la prenderei pure più morbida.
Iniziare magari a invitare qualche amico
che possa essere di un'altra religione in
modo magari pian piano di indorare la
pillola. L'ultima scelta poi la fai tu perché
comunque è una scelta che crea attrito e
che sicuramente non è facilissima da
fare. In bocca al lupo! In bocca al lupo. Ciao ragazzi, oramai
dico ciao ragazzi perché fra te
guglielmo, l'ospite, tuo cugino che
ascolta gli audio prima che... salutiamo a tutti così non si i*****a nessuno. Tutti insieme
ragazzi, Ciao, ciao. Ho letto il tuo messaggio su Facebook
Quel che ti vorrei
chiedere non è una parola di conforto
per me ma più che altro per mia zia, si
guarda tutti i tuoi video, mia zia
Roberta. Lei dalla Sicilia è salita su a
Milano a studiare infermieristica. Dire due
tre paroline e di conforto penso che gli
farebbe tanto piacere
Ciao ragazzi, un bacio. Alla zia gli facciamo
gli auguri in bocca al lupo. Si, in bocca
al lupo! So che è difficile stare lontano da casa
Difficilmente riuscirei a fare quello che fai
che fai tu ma secondo me lo stai facendo per te. Carino questo nipote comunque
Meraviglioso, stupendo Angelo. Ma ormai lui...zia Roberta...zia Roberta...si chiama cosi.
Roberta, veramente in bocca in bocca in
bocca al lupo. Angelo ormai sei un
abituè quindi figurati quando vuoi per
il prossimo tema ti aspettiamo
Ho da poco scoperto che la mia migliore amica,
nonché testimone di nozze, ha tradito il
suo attuale fidanzato, nonchè testimone di nozze di mio marito con una sua
ex vecchia fiamma, fingendo di avere un
lavoro
il weekend che la portava fuori città
appunto, un paio di weekend al mese per
frequentarsi con questo tipo. Non so se metterla con le spalle al muro oppure
se lasciare che sia il tempo che in
qualche modo tirerà fuori questi
scheletri dall'armadio. Grazie mille un bacione. Ah, questo è un gran bel dilemma!
Non direi...tu non diresti? No. O devi dare dei piccoli
indizi che l'altro in qualche modo. Perché poi a
volte le cose non le vogliamo vedere
perché ci fanno male e magari uno lo sa. Però se uno te lo dice "Ah perché me l'hai detto?
Cioè sono quelle situazioni molto ambivalenti...
dove in due secondi diventi il complice in realtà invece
che la persona che sta cercando di...esatto, tu che faresti?
Io credo che stare davanti a una ragazza
che tu sai che si è creata un alibi per
vedersi con un'altra persona, non è che
questa qui una sera ubriaca ha fatto una
cavolata, che comunque è un errore, se tu
sei una sua amica, io quello che farei è
sedermi con lei e dire "Che stai facendo?
Che cos'è che vuoi? Fai una scelta!
Cos'è che ti manca? Quel pizzico di
follia vedi a volte nella vita le
cose ce le dobbiamo veramente complicare. Ma è una roba assurda!
Però credo anche che un amico debba
farti ragionare e debba anche spingerti a
capire che cos'è che vuoi, non si può
avere tutto
No l'amica certo la deve affrontare. Ma
per lei, per te e per lui, è solamente
parlandone che riuscirai a tirar
fuori questa cosa senza però come dicevi
tu, farti troppo coinvolgere, entrare in
quelle dinamiche ambigue. Rientri anche
tu in questo circolo no? Diventi il
cattivo. Rovini l'amicizia perché glie l'hai
detto glie l'hai detto e di colpo ti trovi fra
due fuochi. Però se è amica del cuore trovo giusto
che giustamente si. SI! A muso duro
anche. Fin da quando ero piccola mio
nonno non si è mai presentato, non mi ha
mai dato affetto, non ha mai fatto il
nonno in pratica. Solo ultimamente si
vuole riavvicinare a me, solo che io non
me la sento perché lui appunto è sparito
per tutta la mia vita
Non so come comportarmi, perché non si
merita niente, solo che io non sono una dal
cuore di ghiaccio e rischiare di cedere,
solo che ho paura di rimanere di nuovo delusa
Poi resta il rimpianto di non aver fatto o di
non aver detto anche le cose che si hanno
nel cuore. E' che secondo me a volte uno deve anche
liberarsi no? Cioè "io ce l'ho con te
perché non hai fatto questo". Dirlo,
perché a questo punto uno sta meglio e poi
questi rapporti comunque rinascono sotto
una forma diversa, c'è più sincerità
Magari...verissimo, verissimo...anche l'educazione che uno ha avuto nell'infanzia, tante persone
magari, le persone più anziane
magari, che non c'era la semplicità nel
anche nell'abbracciare i nipoti. Verissimo!
E se non siamo noi i primi a
rompere il ghiaccio, perché io l'ho fatto,
quindi mi rendo conto che con altre
persone, però ho visto poi il
cambiamento che poi abbracciarsi diventa
una cosa naturale. L'inizio uno resta
così. Quindi quelle cose che vanno anche
insegnate e anche in questo caso questo
nonno, vabbè
si è comportato così, avrà avuto i suoi
motivi ma anche lei ne ha i suoi perché
magari è arrabbiata nei suoi confronti. Glie lo
dica però...quelle risposte te le può dare
solamente lui..esatto...e magari fatti
seguire per non scioglierti, perché a
volte il bisogno ci fa dimenticare, passi da gelo a...capito, alla fornace
Fatti magari aiutare dai tuoi genitori
o da, non so se hai un fratello una sorella
o comunque qualcuno che ti permetta
comunque di analizzare la situazione con
relazionalità. Perché se ti ha mandato il
messaggio è perché ci tiene a questo nonno
quindi vuole riallacciare questi rapporti. Esatto bravissima. Parlargli. Esatto
Siamo arrivati alla fine di questo tema.
Io Sonia ti ringrazio ma innanzitutto
per la disponibilità. Ma grazie mi son divertita
...per la tua disponibilità. Ragazzi è stato lo
shooting più lungo della storia, e non la
smettevamo di parlare, quindi ti
ringrazio di cuore per la tua
disponibilità. Grazie a te Gu. Io ringrazio
naturalmente tutte le persone che ci
hanno scritto...naturalmente come si dice "In bocca al
lupo a tutti quanti", "In bocca al lupo, che viva sempre il lupo". E ringrazio voi che ci
avete seguito, vi invito a seguire Sonia.
Sotto vi lascio tutti quanti insomma i
tuoi link. Sto iniziando questa...anche sui social. Brava! Eh certo! Mio figlio mi diceva "Ma
non ci riesci!". Capito? Mi incoraggia in
questo senso. "Sei vecchia ma quindi...". Però è quella
spinta che...esatto...ti farà diventare Chiara
Ferragni. Grazie, grazie. E niente ragazzi noi ci
vediamo la prossima settimana sempre con
un altro video. Vi mando un bacio
Ciao. Ciao